and her husband share this room with
their three children it is the only
space they have at night it's infested
with rodents
and the rent is going up expenses are so
high you know if i have to pay the rent
then i have to give my husband's whole
salary over here because the rent is too
high for just every single room
with energy bills rising feeding her
children has become reliant on other
people's goodwill
but even food banks are struggling
at this one they're expecting a pandemic
level crisis the bills are not going to
hit till the end of this month
so we are you know bracing ourselves for
a big explosion within a couple of
months it was a 400 increase so
you know if it gets to that level it's
going to be another worrying you know as
worrying as it was back then
islamic relief has warned that this
ramadan half of the uk's muslim
community will struggle to feed
themselves its partners say women in
particular are being affected we've seen
particularly an increase in women
applying almost again 100 increase in
the women who are applying for support
and so this is a ramadan where some
people feel a pinch and some people
feeling a full-on body blow
ramadan is a time when muslims tend to
donate even more to charity
last year a record 150 million pounds
was raised in the month for all sorts of
causes from helping victims of war in
yemen to orphans in india and water
wells in senegal
this year there are renewed calls for
help closer to home sadia chowdhury sky
news